good afternoon welcome along to this
meeting of the performance policy and
partnerships committee i'll declare it
open and welcome everybody along via
zoom in the studio in the studio
in the council chamber although two of
us understand that uh councillor lush
and councillor clark
we
have everybody else connecting via zoom
our staff some staff are here as well we
have an apology from his worship uh with
somebody like to move that that is
received counselor skelt uh sorry
council of supreme councillor get
we'll put that all in favor hands up all
right
again
no one carried
um
[Music]
just a reminder
and it's there and
your agenda that if you've got a
declaration of interest
to make it at the time i have
an interest but not a conflict um
on item seven in the agenda um
interest lies in the fact that my wife
is part of the
charitable trust for saving
grace but
i don't believe i have a conflict that
aside i still will not vote
but i will still be able to cheer the
item through the meeting
any other declarations that anybody
would like to make
numb
we'll move into uh there are no items of
public forum that i'm aware of i'll move
into the report from the invercargill
youth council
we don't have any youth councillors here
to speak to it but i was present at the
meeting
i'm happy to move that it's received
councillor crackit is seconding that
yes thank you
if not i'll put that motion all in favor
hands up
hi
against
carried was that an abstention nigel
um
minutes from the august meeting of
performance policy and partnerships
would somebody like to move
true
there's
councillor sopa and councillor lewis
and matt is rising
not i'll put the motion all in favor
hands up
cool thank you
uh proposed
right of way in relation to the
subdivision at 129 regent street uh
michael
the the report that's before you
councillors
does comply with the the council
policies and frameworks so i'll take the
report as read and open to any questions
thanks michael there's two
recommendations there is somebody
willing to move
i should say move council lower
segmented
council amazon thank you
any questions or comments
there's been no objections to the native
no
public
dissension to the suggested names i
would assume
no no incidents
issues that we're aware of this time
thanks for asking graham
so no comments that's been moved in
second i'll put the motion all in favor
thank you
against
carried
which brings us to the
saving grace project updates
rhiannon
thank you chad
cure councillors can you hear me okay
yes awesome um
so i'll take this report
as read this report is bringing back to
the committee for consideration
um terms for the grant that was agreed
as part of the long-term plan
um
for discussion by councillors
thanks rhiannon uh there are three
recommendations there i'm looking for a
mover
councillor emerson secretary councillor
keith
open for questions or comments counselor
edmonton
yeah um i've just got a question really
about the very last recommendation
stating that this hundred thousand
funding will be the total funding
provided to this project by council
just wondering really whether that is
necessary
um and if it is deemed as necessary does
it preclude them from applying to
council funds like the community
wellbeing fund
and future for
parts of the project
around the building and or around the
services that they intend to provide or
host there
really
so um the question as to whether it is
necessary is probably a matter for
discussion by councillors um the second
part is yes it would preclude
coming to council for other
funding towards the project
[Music]
so when you say towards the project do
you mean specifically around the build
um and the refurbishment or do you mean
both that and any future activities that
they
run there themselves
as well
that is a good question um we might need
to amend the wording to be clear on that
if councillors wish to retain that point
d that what was meant by that point was
to enable the completion of the project
to opening i don't think you would want
as councillors to say that at no point
in the future during operation would
they be excluded from applying for
example to the community well-being fund
so my
personal view on this one is that it's
not really necessary and i'd be quite
happy to take it out if other
councillors were happy to take that
particular
weekend remove it
i did
oh yeah
so
thanks so it was moved by bex secular
counselor
rebecca are you
suggesting that you
are amending your motion by withdrawing
item d
yes i would like to do that councillor
kit as the seconder of the motion are
you comfortable with that
i feel that d should remain in there it
states clearly
that it's for this project i know in the
future they'll have numerous projects so
i i feel it should remain in there
okay so
any change then would need to be by way
of amendment because we don't have the
consent of the second
am i allowed to amend something that i
moved
i would rather it came from elsewhere
yeah i'll move the amendment thanks
councillor uh clark is moving in
amendments that d be removed is there a
second for that i'll second that
councillor thank you we'll deal with the
amendment first
uh anybody wishing to speak
to the amendment i have noted that you
yes councillor lewis has said about the
amendment or the motion at large
about the amendment thank you thank you
i wonder if it does have to be changed
because it's funding to the project not
subsequent projects that may be run at
saving grace
for example for something
uh the order might come to creative
communities for uh
venture and that would preclude it
if if
sorry that would not preclude it because
the emotion that actually says to the
project by council
funding provided the project and the
project is pretty specific in the in the
agenda i would have thought
council again were you indicating what
you've already spoken sorry and i'm just
giving a thumbs up to counselor louis
hit the nail on the head oh thank you
anybody else wishing to speak to the
amendment councillor abbott are you just
thumbs upping as well no no or not i
just have a recollection that
when we discussed this originally there
was a tag and the tag was that it was to
be a one-off for this particular
construction
and
thereafter
i felt that people could apply on their
own right or they could apply in their
own right for anything else
so
i don't really see the need for the
amendment but i'll go along with it
okay
can i just get clarification from what
council abbott has said
so if we keep this statement in then
they can't apply for any additional
funding
or the project at all
but what you just said was
it seemed to me like what you were
saying is that they would be able to if
we kept it in
my understanding my understanding from
graeme was that they could still apply
for
the other
funders from the other funding so just
just to clarify what council lewis said
in pardon me for paraphrasing graham uh
was that they would be able to apply for
funding from creative communities which
is a fund essentially that comes in from
outside of council but what rhiannon had
said earlier on is that it would could
well preclude
project grace from applying for anything
else just so that you're aware of where
i'm at i have councillor crackit in
councillor sopa and then councillor kit
so i'll come to council bracket first
um
so but
the amendment then
makes sense to read
that the hundred thousand dollars
funding will be the total funding
provided towards the practical
completion of the construction of the
project and not subsequent activities
so therefore it's only for the
construction portion it doesn't preclude
us for what doesn't preclude them for
applying for any of the subsequent
activities they choose to undertake
okay so just to clarify the amendment is
actually about taking d out altogether
um
well my suggestion would be to alter it
well we've already got an amendment
so that we'll have to either uh succeed
or fail before we can look at another
one okay
sorry are you comfortable with that
of course
well you know not comfortable that's
sort of sofa
thanks mr chair as the seconder of the
amendment i was just going to clarify
because i thought some other councillors
might have picked up that the amendment
um wasn't quite what it meant so the
amendment is to remove d altogether
if d is removed altogether as the
seconder
my
understanding then is
that saving grace could apply for any
subsequent project or activity
but we have already told saving grace
when the hundred thousand was granted
that it was a one-off
so we already have
the same grass has already been told the
hundred thousand is the only hundred
thousand for this project
um
my feeling was to leave it in rather
clouds the waters we would not
want
um this particular saving grace to be
the only organization we had ever told
could not apply for any other activity
so my feeling was it clarified the
situation to remove d altogether
thank you councillor kit
yeah just a a comment uh i feel that
they should be left then as i said but
just change a couple of words that this
hundred thousand funding will be the
total funding provided
to
this project only by council
that will cover everything yeah well
we'll see if we get to that point
final right of speaking to the amendment
is with councillor clark yeah thank you
chair um
no i i still stick with the um amendment
that these excluded or withdrawn
um because i think the statement made by
the staff member
um created a level of ambiguity that we
were not aware of
that it could preclude other things
we've given an undertaking to them that
it's a hundred thousand um if they
wanted more and if that was a
possibility they wanted more we still
have the right to say no
and we're only committing in this to
what we've already verbally committed to
them and i think that
having that in there
if it does preclude other applications
is confusing
thank you
okay we're now going to vote on the
amendment which is the removal of item d
from the recommendations
all those in favor of the removal of
item d if you can raise your hand
two in the room
and two in the room
the amendment is carried
so essentially the we go back to the
original motions which is
recommendations one two and three and
recommendation three it's a b and c
uh i think in in summation before we
open up for discussion on that
um councillor kai was was right in what
he said that
there's been a good indication given
that
the amount is what we have signaled to
project grace
we're comfortable with giving but it
doesn't preclude them from coming back
for something else at some other point
really it's about the 100 000 for the
next year
showing in the long term plan
so coming back to the original
recommendations are there any other
counselors who wish to speak
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
if you can raise your hand
carried thank you
that brings us to item eight which is
helicopter trust uh funding councillor
clark would you like to to speak to this
man thank you chair um
so um as part of an approach by the
trust to the southland mural form um
i gave an undertaking that i would raise
this issue um
through the paper that's come up um
i understand that there has been some
previous applications by the trust
and it may well be that as an outcome of
today that we may well seek
an officer's report
that gives us some backstory to it um
but certainly at the mayoral forum um
there was a discussion about um
what each of the three councils would
pay
um and and certainly what i was putting
forward is subject to the other two
parties also contributing when we're
the papers there and uh
what outcomes people want
thank you councillor clack um
i think the
second item in the recommendation is is
key oh sorry the third item is is key
and that the 50 000 that's looking at
being contributed from icc
um
is contingent on both south and district
angle district contributing to the
levels as indicated i understand
your district are discussing it this
afternoon
but i guess mr day what we're going to
need is just a brief paper that
indicates uh what the effect is on the
annual plan portion of the long-term
plan around how that funding is made and
if we can get that
um i think it might help provide some
clarity councillor sopa
thanks mr chair um look i've got
absolutely no doubt about the the worthy
cause of the helicopter trust and of
course i absolutely support the trust
um my
slight concern
is that i thought as council we had
discussed the arrangements we've made
with the community well-being fund
as a way of
listening the
one-off approaches by a lot of
organizations in an ad hoc manner after
we had
finalized a long-term plan and so forth
so i'm just um wanting some advice i
suppose from staff
as to why this would not fit into um
suggesting an application to the
community while being funded
can i just come to councillor lewis
first of all because i know it was
suggested that it goes in his direction
but councillor get i have noted that you
want to speak as well thank you so
councillor lewis
we do in the community wellbeing fund
have a
rather
strict
rating system point system there's no
guarantee that would fulfill a high
ranking in that
that situation until we had a formal
application we'd have to do budgets
um
effectively
posteriors on seats
and
how they would benefit to the actual
city and a city city
committee will be funded funded
a lot to be
around the the center city
activity in the city rather than the
very well
and well
meaning thought of the helicopter trust
thanks but i would have to see a full
application first touch you
um
rhiannon do you have some
feedback on that comment just before i
come to council again
in the report which was brought back we
could certainly touch on the matter as
to where and the channel through which
the funding ought to go um if it was
decided to deal with it separately
um it would still be possible for
example to give us scoring against what
it would have scored had it gone through
the community well-being fund
this might be a matter that the chief
executive has another comment on no
i think it's just something to quickly
reference in the report how it may have
done against that that matrices but uh
really the effect on the annual slash
long-term plan
um
would be what we need and i think by
that stage we'll also have an indication
of where things are going with the other
councils i'll come to you in just a
moment councillor council keith thank
you for your patience
yeah thank you mr chairman yep it's uh
it's a great project run by great people
and i do support it
but i'm just want to ask a question how
much do the lakes district council
contribute
um
i'm not sure about the district council
they had it when they presented
and jules um presented he had a list of
business people in the lakes district
that were contributing
and they seemed to range from about 10
000 to about 20 25 000
and he had a list of donations the trust
gets a significant amount of operating
costs from the central government it's
one of the
designated
helicopter rescue systems in the south
island and one of three
but it doesn't get um funding for
specialized equipment
and for training as well
so that's where they have to fundraise
answer your question counsellor
partially partially
i was on council when this application
for a summer application came a few
years ago
and another question was asked then was
what percentage of southern people would
use the service because uh the question
that was posed then
was the queenstown as a tourist mecca
not going too well at the moment we know
why
and that was only a handful of
southerners would use this service
so i just wonder if there's any if they
get there's any figures of what's
happened in the past so there are two
trusts actually but counselor clark
might be able to help out there so um
that question was asked when we had the
uh southland mayoral forum
um and and there was two bits of
information that came back that led me
to support this application
the first one was that
it's um
the is provided for the southern region
um
wakatibu and south and it goes up as far
as part of
otago as well
and as the presenter said it's not a
matter of um
does the invercargill city with its
boundaries get benefit from this because
we all in southland travel out into
those outlying areas that surround us so
out into the district
the area is the first option um and he
said the other side of it is they have
quite a bit of work transferring from
uh our local hospital through the
dunedin hospital which is a tertiary
hospital
so we we definitely get better benefit
of the latter
um but when i asked jules specifically
um
what's your what's your predominant
workload is it uh tourists that get lost
in the bush is it people living out
outlying areas and he said no it's just
people in southland that are traveling
within southam and it was ironic the day
that he put his application the shop was
sitting in the main street of
picking up from an accident
just before i come to your counselor but
it might be useful if the paper also
detailed the other helicopter trusts
operating in the area because i think
they are also involved in patient
training yeah there's one in dunedin
yeah councillor air but thank you
you just made the point about the other
operating
and they do transfer from hospital as a
council of sofa and others i know and
i've been a frequent flyer on some of
them
unfortunately and well well looked after
and well cared for with absolute care
and comfort so i'm going to support it
but i agree that we need to talk to
michael and just see how our funding
streams are and if we could make that as
part of the recommendation
i'd be happy to move it
right so your recommendation is because
we didn't actually have one on the table
um
very generous of me letting
discussion go so far is that we call for
a report
uh seeking clarification on the
financial implications and more detail
on the
other trusts that are operating within
the area
which was secreted i think by councillor
kit
is that right
councillor clark
just as a final thing we're always
mindful of what the impact is going to
be for households or for ratepayers
um
some quick maths would show you this all
this uh support of 50 000 will cost the
average household 2.50 per year
so not a significant amount
and
thanks you're right and when you break
it down like that it is
a small amount but a little bit of
clarity and if we can get that back to
the october meeting and we can make a
recommendation to council at that point
it would be good
so is everybody clear on the motion the
motion is that we're calling for a
report from mr day on the financial
implications of the recommendation of
providing fifty thousand dollars to the
helicopter trust
um
contingent on funding support from both
south and district and gore district
councils
uh with financial implications on the
ltp and details on other trusts
operating
i'll put that all in favor hands up
against
carried thank you for that
which brings us to the activity reports
for a very um interesting period things
were
starting oh so well
before
covered straight
reaching over for the microphone
it'll be a joint effort who wants to go
first kiara koto
uh councillors
so over lockdown
we saw our teams work
very closely to
maintain our services
for the community
we did see an increase in customer
contact which was positively received
in the call center
and we're able to um assure
our community that they would not be
facing penalties for rates or dogs so
again that will be uh comes into effect
on the 21st of this month so next week
we were impacted in our planning team
after lockdown by not being able to
visit some sites but we have contacted
those customers
and saw a slight delay with some
building consents
our limbs remained reasonably steady and
also our property file requests we are
scanning on demand
for customers for those properties and
that's been very well received
and what else can i tell you
we did receive a number of noise
complaints over lockdown and also
we continued to manage some challenging
animal control situations through our
team and with the assistance of the
police so
those things were still in operation and
um
we're following through
on any further work in those areas and i
welcome any questions before i hand on
to my colleague thanks treaty just in
relation to the um
[Music]
animal attacks
uh
any of them
likely to result in prosecution or is
that still a matter that's resting with
the police still a matter of resting
with the police we're just reviewing
things
council is any other questions for trudy
steve
thank you mr chair um look i think
you've summarised up
the bulk of our report from the news and
recreation group a really good start to
the year
and we're now going to have some
interesting results over the coming
months as we deal with the impact of
lockdown
i'm so happy to take any questions on
this report too
council has any questions for steve
if there are none look i'll just
reinforce that you know things were
tracking along nicely until mid august
and then we got thrown a quick curveball
let me praise the staff for the
seamless way in which they've been able
to transition
in ensuring uninterrupted service
delivery
it's been less
a feeling our way as we go process this
time
there were learnings from our first time
in lockdown and it's made the transition
uh a lot easier um i think you know
there were a lot of questions around
uh overdue books
and and payment of rates and fears
around those which
uh through our comms team we moved to
alleviate as quickly as we could in
making people aware that once we shifted
down to level two from that date um they
would have two weeks in which to pay and
even as i came into the civic
administration building today there was
still just somebody a seeking
clarification
uh about that from front of house staff
and be positively responding to
the fact that we had had done so in that
way so um thanks to your teams for for
the way that they've maybe been able to
adjust and continue to service somebody
like to move that the activity report is
received thank you
council lewis and councillor abbott it's
open for questions or comments if there
are any others
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
against
carried
thank you very much uh councillors there
being no further business that is uh
going to be the end of our live stream
thank you to those who have joined us uh
but if you can remain online we will
have
a workshop presentation